I mean even thinking about us being in
quarantine for over a month like I'm
going crazy a little bit crazy so I can
only imagine what it's like for IRS to
be stuck in this here world I have to
see that me reverse warps the mind until
the person is no longer recognizable if
iris is still alive in there there's
probably nothing left of her to save
thank you so much for taking time out of
your social distancing time to hand out
the flash how are you it's I'm good I
have so much time so it's nothing to
take time to talk to you it's good to
see you it's so good to see you I have
been loving this season for iris we got
so much ace reporter iris you know that
you and I have been chatting about this
for many years what was that like for
you to really see her build up team
citizen and and just really declare that
this is who she is and this is what
she's going after yeah it was it's great
I mean as you've said we've had many
many talks over the last six years about
iris her being a reporter and I'm really
having her own agency and not just being
a wife or a member of Team flash but you
know following in her passion and doing
what she can to helps City Central City
in our own way and so it was really
exciting for me to see that and to see
Eric bring in two other females to join
to citizen diverse else he really had
this idea of this kind of like Charlie's
Angels empowered teen citizen and so I
was really excited about it we have you
know two great actresses that joined and
it's been really really good seeing you
rock your curly hair this season was
such a highlight talk to me about how
that came about and and just let that
meant for you to really just be able to
show your true self yeah well it was an
opportunity I remember Eric had
mentioned it was going to be a really
really late episode for for grant and I
would shoot maybe one day if that yeah I
think it was like half a day and the
premise was we were going on a little
mini vacation and I thought well this is
really easy to kind of do something
different if we wanted to in terms of
hair and if it didn't work it was
something that you know would be quickly
kind of like move past but it was really
exciting
for me and nerve-racking for me you know
what something you haven't done on the
show being a woman of color and not
having a lot of access to live in a
color doing my hair and doing my natural
hair was a little bit scary but they
were very patient with me and they may
be comfortable and I think it turned out
great Mick seemed to have a really
powerful important response which is
what I wanted
I remember Jesse saying to me he was
like if you can't wear your hair the way
it grows out of your own head then
that's a problem and so I just felt like
it was really important for me before I
left the show whenever that ends that we
saw iron saw me in my natural hair which
I wear often when I'm not on the show
definitely oh that makes me so excited
yeah and girl you know I've been
tweeting up a storm because you have
been crushing season six so much seeing
you play this mirror iris this this
alternate version of the character that
you've been playing for the past six
seasons has been so much fun to watch
take me into your brain a little bit
when you're wrapping your head around
and crafting this new version of iris
what did you really want to get right
well for me it was like in the beginning
I was asking Erik how close is this
version of iris to the iris we know and
love and he was like 98% want her to be
a lievable enough that Barry would not
catch on very quickly that team flash
wouldn't catch on so I just wanted to
build in these like small subtle nuances
that the audience would see and that
maybe members of team flash would say
that that's a little off you know she's
she is our iris and there are parts of
her that we know and recognize and love
but something is amiss so I didn't want
to go heavy-handed on like I'm a villain
but I just really wanted to build any
small moments of like yeah something's
not right with her and she's not the
iris that we know and love and being
able to play that and being able to be a
villain like I don't know how many
opportunities I would have to do that on
this show it's been really really fun
everyone wants to be bad once in a while
I was so excited to finally see that
Barry did catch on realize that that is
not his wife what was your reaction when
you saw that very would eventually
figure out the truth yeah it's a cool
while but I was you know like everyone
believed and finally caught on and that
you know we all want him to come save
iris we all love iris and want to get
her out of the mirror so I was happy to
read the script of like okay it's
finding me in motion it's fine
everyone's finally catching on we're
gonna get her out of there mm-hmm well
as we approach what is now six 19 the
finale of the flash there's still so
much left up in the air naturally a lot
of flash episodes end on a cliffhanger
so I know that this one work as a finale
how are you feeling though knowing that
this six season this is cut short I mean
it's it's bittersweet you know I think
for everyone I think the writers and
actors and the crew and everyone
involved saw what it was going to end
like obviously that's the version we
wanted to give to fans you know who
loved this show and just given the
current global situation that's
impossible and so we kinda have to do
the best with what we've got and like
you said fortunately our shows kind of
always end on the cliffhanger and so I
have no idea actually how they plan to
kind of tie it up with a with a bow
that's thankfully it's something I don't
have to deal with but it's it's hard
it's you know it's not how we intended
it to be but it's we're gonna make the
best of it and I think hopefully the
intention is to come back and resolve
the story and kick up season seven
you know resolving everything that's
happened in season six like we've been
seeing that with Iris stuck in the
mirror world it's really wrenching with
her brain
something's going on do you think that
this is something that might have
long-term effects on her yeah that's a
great question something I've been
thinking about I mean like you said I
mean even thinking about us being in
quarantine for over a month like I'm
going crazy
a little bit crazy so I can only imagine
what it's like for IRS to be stuck in
this mirror world with this sinister
person Eva McCulloch and the damages
that it's gonna have on her mentally not
to mention just the ramifications of you
know reading everything in mirror
language and the long-term effects of
that and also feeling like maybe there's
some resentment that the teams didn't
figure it out soon enough and come get
her sooner I mean there's so many
aspects that we could play with in how
this could you know potentially affect
iris in the future mm-hmm definitely we
are coming up on the end of season six
yeah how does that make you feel it's
crazy it feels like I've been doing this
for my whole life to be honest and it
also feels like a blink of an eye
like I women i season one Comic Con and
that feels like yesterday and so there
are moments where I'm like oh my god
I've been in the show forever I mean
there's moments where I'm also like
where did the time go
like what how did it just come this far
this fast so it's it's just a real
constantly when I think about you know
the stories we've been able to tell the
fans we've been able to reach
it's overwhelming that we've been gifted
with the opportunity to be on air this
long and be loved by fans and critics
alike it's really I don't know that I
will have many of these opportunities in
my career I can only hope but for one of
my first big shows to be this loved this
well looked-after it's just it's a gift
to not always kind of remember that
definitely do you see yourself how many
more seasons do you see yourself playing
iris west-allen
I don't know that's kind of up in the
air I know I'm contracted through season
seven so I've definitely got one more
anything actually um but you know
anything's fair game after that it's
just out of where the show goes what
they want to look like how I feel
towards the end of season seven but a
lot kind of go into you know why I show
continues and stays on the air if grant
and the other cast members want to stay
there's a lot get a lot
well what is still on your iris wish
list what would you like to see from her
we've seen so much this season but
there's still so much more I'd love to
see I haven't really thought about that
that's a great question because I've
never really thought of it like coming
to an end I feel like it'll just go
forever but um I mean selfishly I would
agree I would love to relive her as a
superhero I would love to kind of have
one more kind of look it may be her and
Barry tema as a super teen I don't know
that'd be something really cool to to
relive definitely I would also love to
see more of just the West Island family
as a whole maybe Nora coming back no
coming back god Jessica Parker Kennedy
was so great it was such a great she was
fantastic our app is a lovely human
being like I would love to see in some
way us revisit that story that character
in a small way you know I'm always
wanting Kenan back more of just Martin
you just like you said more of the West
Allen's family aspect of the show which
is the heart of the show I think more of
that it's always better definitely well
how's everything going with you
personally how Zoe what's going on
Candice how you do it Zoe's great she's
wandering around huh we walks together
you know I'm just like everybody else
trying to get through this time is so
weird
so weird it's you know I feel like I was
made for this moment I'm such a recluse
old like preparing for quarantine so
there's an aspect of me that really
enjoys it but at the same time I think
like everybody I want to get back to
normal life I want to see my friends and
I hug my friends I you know I want to
enjoy Cinco de Mayo and want to you know
drink margaritas but you know I try to
just be positive and realize that this
is more than just having a margarita
it's about everyone's take and I'm just
trying to do my part to keep you know
everyone safe well lastly Candace is
there anything else that you wanted to
talk about or anything that you were
excited to mention or anything you want
to say to your fans no I'm just sad that
we won't see you guys at Comic Con this
year it's such a I know for comical fans
and flash fans you know how much it
means to them and how it means to us
it's one of the rare opportunities we
have during the season to kind of
connect with fans and and share in that
special moment and so it's it's really
sad that we won't have that this year
and I'm hoping there's something we can
do to kind of connect the fans that
different way I'm working on on
something because I feel like I've
mastered wrangling you guys as a group
you have kind of hopefully doing a
virtual comic on zoom' I would love it I
feel like you know that gives some fans
it means so much to them and so I know
it's disappointing hopefully we can do
something to get back to them or just
the last thing I want to say is everyone
stay safe you know do your part and
hopefully you know this will be over
before we know it amazing Candace you
are such a gem it's always a delight to
chat with you
[Music]